what about calcium normally people are
not deficient because of calcium itself
it's all the cofactor so in order for
calcium to go to the right places it
really depends on a lot of the cofactors
if you're eating sufficient meat your
stress levels are reduced when you're
stressed you will bleed out more calcium
so it's not a I'm not eating sufficient
calcium I know people get worried well I
don't eat fish I don't eat fish with
bones and then I don't eat dairy so
where am I getting my calcium normally
it's not the calcium itself if you need
calcium you can always supplement but
typically speaking it's usually like the
cofactor vitamin D or magnesium or high
stress in the life of too much cortisol
for example so I would look into a
little bit of the cofactors of calcium
make sure that that is all sufficient
and then if it's still imbalanced that's
when you can then consider calcium
there's a lot of studies that show I
think it's like mid-age women they
supplement calcium and then they have
higher risk of heart disease so I
normally don't recommend calcium right
away